say kids would you like to hear a story
cause we've got a really good one for
you
seriously you're going to love it it's a
classic rags to riches tale about one
man's rise from humble beginnings to
become one of history's greatest and
most visionary toy makers or maybe it
isn't maybe it's about a company that
literally came from nothing whose
origins are still shrouded in mystery
maybe it's about a woman breaking the
glass ceiling to take over the toy
company left to her by her eccentric
father maybe it's about all of these
things but the one thing we can tell you
about the story of dr wondertainment is
that every word of it is true or at
least as far as anything is true in the
weird wonderful world of the scp
foundation as long as you believe we'll
all have a wonderful time as long as you
believe
nothing can hurt you
not in the fabulous world of doctor
wondertainment dr wondertainment is the
name given to scp-001
who due to his relatively benign nature
has been classified as safe by the
foundation rather than focusing on
containing wondertainment himself the
scp foundation has centered its efforts
on containing the products that he
creates he is a class one reality warper
capable of constructing otherwise normal
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially
dangerous toys and games that are
distributed by as yet unknown means
many of wondertainment's toys are in the
foundation's possession such as
scp-445 origami paper that takes on
properties of whatever it's folded to
look like and
scp-3147 lollipops that allow people to
switch voices with each other dr
wondertainment was born into a family of
humble means his mother was a seamstress
and his father was an accountant
unsatisfied with his mundane life
wondertainment's only joy growing up was
in the stories that his father would
tell him about an ancestor of his who
was once a famous toy maker inspired by
these stories wundertainment developed
an interest in crafting toys and as an
adult set out to learn the secrets he
would need to create toys unlike
anything the world had ever seen he
spent his life following rumors of
magical artifacts and enchanted trinkets
until his search brought him to a
mysterious factory if you've seen our
previous videos on scp-001 proposals you
can probably guess that this factory was
the factory the mysterious place where
new scps are supposedly created
wondertainment barely escaped the
massacre and the foundation takeover of
the factory with his life but he was
able to find a variety of notes that he
took with him these notes contained
clues that led him to the workshop of
his famous toymaker ancestor and from
there he reclaimed his birthright that
was the day that he truly became doctor
wondertainment it's a fun story isn't it
very straightforward but perhaps it is a
little underwhelming for an scp-001
proposal after all
scp-001 is the collective designation
given to some of the most important
anomalies of all time including many
that could have potentially been
involved in the foundation's very
founding hmm let's start again
reginald filbert lionel archibald
westinghouse entertainment iii is the
name given to scp-001
who due to his highly unpredictable
nature has been classed as euclid by the
foundation and he is to be detained as
soon as his location can be
ascertained until he can be captured the
scp foundation has focused its efforts
on containing the products that he
creates he is a class 2 reality warper
capable of constructing otherwise normal
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and
potentially dangerous toys games candy
soft drinks and other products aimed at
children and young teens these products
are distributed by as yet unknown means
many of wondertainment's creations are
in foundation possession such as the
often imitated but never matched little
misters collection which are a group of
living collectibles with unique
anomalous properties due to
entertainment's reality warping
abilities it is impossible to pin down
concrete information about his history
what we can tell you for sure is that
he's immortal and ageless and comes from
a long line of wondertainment stretching
all the way back to the cretaceous
period where they made all sorts of toys
for the good little dinosaur children
it's also widely known that he is in
fact not a real person but merely the
manifestation of the dreams of every
child on earth brought forth solely by
the power of imagination no confirmed
sightings of dr wondertainment have ever
occurred but witnesses have described
him as dashing very handsome for his age
and a lovely chap capable of creating
whimsy and wonder with the snap of his
fingers he's a tall man about the height
of a piece of string and he's
immediately recognizable by his walking
stick and w-shaped mustache it's also
been reported that he has scarring
around the circumference of both wrists
almost as if his hands have been removed
and reattached at some point however the
truth of the matter is that
hmm no no we're telling it all wrong
again this doesn't do anything to
capture the scope of the wondertainment
story it needs to feel
bigger
more
comprehensive
let's try it again
dr wondertainment is a trademark of the
wondertainment toy company the name
given to scp-001
a corporation that due to its consistent
output of anomalous items is classed by
the foundation as ketter until this
company can be permanently shut down the
scp foundation has focused its efforts
on containing the products that it
creates the collective power of the
company's constituent employees and the
technology they make use are equivalent
to that of a class 3 reality warper the
wondertainment company produces and
sells a range of products ranging from
the seemingly normal to the downright
weird all imbued with anomalous
properties the company has become
infamous for their constant output of
bizarre magical and potentially
dangerous toys games candy soft drinks
and other products aimed at children
teens and young at heart adults these
products are made and distributed from
wonder world trademark a location that
is yet unknown to the foundation but
offers factory tours every hour from
tuesday to friday many of
wundertainment's creations are in
foundation possession such as
wondertainment's famous dragon snails
the real fire-breathing pet you can keep
in your pocket not much is known about
the inner workings of the wondertainment
company the scp foundation has no
information currently on the company's
leadership structure location history or
corporate policies various former and
current employees have been interviewed
regarding their experiences working for
wondertainment but they never seem to be
able to remember very much of use those
interviewed variously described the
wondertainment company as a regular
office building an immense toy factory
an amusement park but all agree it's the
best place they ever worked in fact you
should apply for a job there we i i mean
they have a few openings in their legal
department or so i've heard oh silly me
it seems we've gotten off topic you're
here to hear about the scp-001 proposal
posting a job ad wasn't what i meant to
do when i hacked into
i mean well don't worry about that
forget i said a thing now let's try this
again but this time we'll add a twist
isabel helga anastasia parvati
wondertainment v is the name given to
scp-001
who due to her ability to spread
sunshine and whimsy wherever she goes
has been classed as thomiel by the
foundation and due to her immensely
unpredictable nature the scp foundation
has resolved to just leave her be
because she can't be captured the scp
foundation has focused its efforts on
containing the products that she creates
she is a class 4 reality warper capable
of constructing wonderful funtastic
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties she's famous and widely
beloved for using this ability to create
bizarre magical and not even a little
bit dangerous toys games candy soft
drinks and other products aimed at
everyone from ages 9 to 99. these
products are distributed by as yet
unknown means many of wundertainment's
creations are in foundation possession
such as
scp-3551 the awesome inflatable alien
invaders and
scp-2514 a lovely horse who can sing
happy birthday
how grabbed wondertainment inherited the
wondertainment name from her father who
either passed away or never existed at
all the circumstances of his death and
perhaps non-existence were very
messy involving a mass murderer the
leader of a shadowy international extra
governmental paramilitary organization
at least one deity and four bent
paperclips she owns six corgis and all
of them are named jeremy in a free time
she likes to
no
no this is all still wrong all right
enough is enough you want to know who dr
wondertainment really is well you asked
for it dr wondertainment is the name
given to scp-001
who due to his deity level power has
been classed as apollyon by the
foundation there is no possible way to
contain him he is a class five reality
warper capable of breaking down and
reconstructing the very laws of reality
did you really think that those little
trinkets were the full extent of my i
mean
his creations did you truly think of him
as such a small petty creature dr
wondertainment is no mere toy smith no
he is a god want examples of his
creations just look around you
everything from the most innocent safe
class to the most harrowing ketter class
it's all thanks to him he is behind
everything marshall carter and dark the
sarcasts the church of the broken god
even the scarlet king himself all that
time all that effort all it came down to
was one entity
one singular living personification of
chaos one day the scp foundation will
finally give up trying to find out how
he distributes his products when they
will finally see how small and worthless
their attempts to restore order really
are and they will be driven before his
power they will crumble and decay into
nothingness you will bow before doctor
wondertainment
[Laughter]
had you going for a second there didn't
we you should have seen the looks on
your faces but let's start again
one more time we're being serious this
time mask off here's the true story of
dr wondertainment dr wondertainment is
the name given to scp-001
who due to his relatively benign nature
has been classed as neutralized by the
foundation rather than focusing on
containing wondertainment himself the
scp foundation has focused its efforts
on containing the products that he
creates he is a reality warper whose
limits have yet to be documented capable
of constructing otherwise normal objects
and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially dangerous toys
in games that are distributed by as yet
unknown means due to his secretive
nature almost nothing is known of dr
wondertainment's true origins and the
waters have been muddied extensively by
the side effects of his reality warping
ability in fact it's entirely possible
that dr wondertainment himself doesn't
know who he is anymore it's possible
that all the proposed origins and
descriptions of dr wondertainment are
true in their own way but it is equally
possible that none of them are all
that's known for sure is that dr
wondertainment be they male or female
corporation or single individual is a
constant thorn in the scp foundation's
side no matter who they really are
they're not going away soon
and only time will tell who they'll be
tomorrow or what further horrors they
and their company will create and that's
where our story will have to come to an
end at least for now we hope you enjoyed
it and remember keep believing now go
check out
scp-001 which is the real zero zero one
and scp-001 the children or boro cycle
for more knowledge on the mysterious and
elusive scp-001